hello there I see you clicked on the
video I guess now you're wondering why
good question
well first obviously the video had to
exist for you to click on it so partly
you clicked on the video because I made
the video but of course the video also
needed to be shared on a public platform
for you to see it and click on it which
in this case was YouTube so I guess it's
also because of YouTube that you clicked
on the video but YouTube only exists
because some guys named Chad Hurley
jollywood cream and Steve Chen made
YouTube back in 2005 so I guess it's
because some guys named Chad John and
Steve are born and met up at some point
in their lives but they were really only
able to create YouTube because of the
internet and the internet only exists
because of the guys who invented the
internet whose names are Robert econ and
Ben Seraph but they were only able to
invent the internet because they had
access to a programmable computer which
was invented by another guy named Conrad
Zeus Zeus invented the first
programmable computer in 1938 which has
built almost entirely out of thin metal
sheets so technically you clicked on
this video because metal exists okay so
without YouTube no video without
internet no YouTube without computer no
internet without metal no computer but
where did metal come from metal is
primarily found in the Earth's crust so
metal comes from the earth but the earth
only exists because of a gas cloud
that's spun enough to condense and
produce the Sun and the earth several
billion years ago which happened because
billions of years before that the Big
Bang occurs in form time and space and
things to allow for things to happen so
I guess you really only clicked on this
video because time and space and things
started 13.7 three billion years ago but
what about you you must have played a
role in all this I mean you chose to be
on YouTube and you chose to click on
this video right well why did you choose
to be on YouTube right now as opposed to
nearly an infinite amount of other
things you could have chosen to do with
your time and what caused this video to
appear on your YouTube feed or wherever
else you found it and why did you choose
to click on it instead of scrolling past
it and why are you someone with access
to the Internet and why do you even
exist as a thing that can know what the
internet is in the first place the
universe is made up of atoms that
function off of cause and effect
patterns 13.7 billion years ago the Big
Bang ignited a string of events causes
and effects bumps and crashes
emergencies and emergence where ever
became everything in an exact order in
an exact amount of time
this sequence eventually led to the
creation of a gas cloud earth metal a
guy named Conrad two more guys named
Robert invent three more guys named Chad
Joe wood and Steve YouTube this video
and you being here on YouTube at this
exact time with your exact brain all in
the perfect position for you to see this
video and want to click on it
if this is true would that mean that all
of this was predetermined was I destined
to create this video you destined to see
and click on it if right now the
universe suddenly stopped completely and
everything dissolved back into nothing
you me this video YouTube the internet
planet Earth the Sun the galaxy the
universe everything just stopped and
then it all started over the Big Bang
occurred all over again just as it did
13.7 billion years ago in 13.7 billion
years from now would you be here
watching the same video all over again
if the universe functions off of cause
and effect sequences carried out by the
interaction of atoms and you are made up
of atoms and your brain is made up of
atoms like everything else in the
universe you exist in function based off
of cause and effect patterns so if the
universe started over exactly how it did
13.7 billion years ago
just like how knocking down dominoes
placed exactly the same way with the
same wind and temperature conditions
would lead to the last domino falling in
the exact same place in the exact same
amount of time every time in 13.7
billion years from now all the particles
of the universe would have bumped and
crashed and buzzed in the same order
creating the same solar system sun earth
metal computer Internet YouTube this
video and you watching it so after all
that you clicked on this video because
you didn't have a choice now you might
argue that if I didn't title or
thumbnail this video in this way you
wouldn't have chosen to click on it and
therefore you would have had freedom of
choice because of a reason the reason
being that you chose to click on it
based on whether or not the title or
thumbnail provoked or interested you but
why did this video's title or thumbnail
provoke or interest you and did you have
any say in it in general do you decide
what interests you or not know things
just do or don't you are free to click
on this video because you wanted to but
you weren't free to want to click on
this video to truly claim that you chose
to click on this video on your own free
you would have had to have chosen
whether or not you were exposed to this
video and if its title and thumbnail
would interest you prior to even knowing
that the video existed but you didn't do
that and you couldn't do that you don't
know why you decided to open up YouTube
or whatever source brought you here you
don't know why you were interested in
this video you don't know why you
clicked on it you just did because
everything led you here arguably it is
impossible to argue that we have free
will our choices are determined by
neurophysiological events in the brain
which are determined by our genes
childhoods and life experiences all of
which have wired our brains in a certain
way none of which we had any say in our
lives are determined by the forces of
cause and effect that exists outside of
our control the things that happen that
caused you to be born you did not choose
the things that caused you to be born to
your specific parents and a certain part
of the world you did not choose the
things that cause you to be male or
female taller small lighter dark skinned
you did not choose the things that have
passed by you the words you have heard
the feelings you've experienced you did
not choose any of it and you cannot
choose what any of it will cause you to
do and feel in this moment or any other
moment essentially that means that
nothing you do is really your choice and
wouldn't that mean that there's no point
in doing anything no point in trying no
point in caring if we are no different
than the atoms around and inside of us
operating with no control over their
movements and placements and time and
space then isn't everything we do
meaningless and not worth putting effort
towards no fortunately for us that is
not the case you can't truly choose who
you are or who you become you can't
choose what happens or has happened to
you but you can choose what to do with
it all how to observe it how to
experience and embrace the movement of
it when you get in a car and you put a
seat belt on or at least you should even
though you have no control over the
conditions of the roads and the other
drivers on the roads you still put a
seatbelt on you have no choice in the
fact that you know what a seat belt is
as well as no choice in the feeling of
fear for what not having a seat belt
might cause but your response to this
knowledge and fear can still save your
life if you are hit you observe the
knowledge and feeling towards putting a
seat belt on so you do
you're hit this action can save you
regardless of subjective choice you are
not an inactive participant in your life
your participation and actions are
necessary
you must try and care likewise when you
have a goal dream interest passion or
curiosity you don't not do anything
because the universe predestined you to
end up somewhere instead you follow your
goals dreams interest passions and
curiosities you respond to the world
around them you do things you find out
where you'll end up you click on the
video and you hopefully enjoy it
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder